Donald Trump had a New Year's Eve party
at Mar-A-Lago on New Year's Eve he
announced that he would be available to
the media barely any media showed up and
Trump dodged questions and generally
seemed extremely confused we're going to
look at a couple of Clips just to ring
in the New Year together
uh Trump was asked a question about a
National Abortion ban he ignores it
calls on a different reporter Trump
looks disoriented Melania looks
miserable it's all just crazy
Mr President
so he's asked would you support a
National Abortion ban he doesn't like
the question he just calls on someone
else let's let's watch it again
Mr President the doj and FBI have
weaponized against you will you commit
to going after them in your second term
this is a question he likes I think it's
a disgrace
the weaponization of Justice never been
anything
was great and thank you for that
question
that question he appreciates
um at another moment
um he's asked about Ron DeSantis and
then he talks about the border of
Ukraine and Russia it doesn't make any
sense what he's saying it's just totally
confused garbled speech I do apologize
also because the audio isn't great on
this segment but I think we'll be able
to hear it
foreign
the few questions he's getting half of
him he doesn't like
I've been killing a lot of people
with Ukraine and Russia
[Music]
inflation
destroying their country
Mr President so this is a section from
before the doj and FBI have weaponized
against you will you commit to going
after them in your second term I think
it's great and thank you for that
question
all right anyway as you can see almost
no media showed up you see a microphone
from oan there and just really really
failing and then inside the party Donald
Trump offered the following
inspirational and uplifting message
going into the new year
we're watching inflation going through
the roof
all of these things that we're watching
and so unnecessary and so sad to see now
we have airports where people can't fly
the only good thing is connected from
this standpoint we needed some seats so
we lost about 50 we sold about 200 next
time so but it's sad when people can't
come from New York to Florida the
airports are like we're like a third
world country there you go an
inspirational message of peace and love
we are like a third world country and
people can't fly anymore so listen it's
going we're sort of poking fun at this
because it's ridiculous and hilarious
and pathetic but um I have no idea what
to expect for 2023. if you came to me
and you said sir by the end of 2023
Will trump even still be a candidate for
the Republican nomination I don't know
where I would bet on an even money bet I
don't know if I take the bet that Trump
will still be a candidate by the end of
this year uh or that he will not very
difficult to say things are odd things
are strange and we're just getting
started
one of our sponsors today is zipx
nicotine toothpicks zipx brings you a
convenient alternative to smoking and
vaping and The Vape clouds the ashtrays
the thing in your lip that people can
see I've seen that around this is an
easier and less messy way to curb the
cravings and you can use zipx just about
anywhere zipx is available in six
flavors with two or three milligram
strength the nicotine and the flavor are
long lasting and zipix has helped
countless people kick the bad habits and
they are bad habits zipx toothpicks are
FDA registered their customer service is
second to none it is one of the most
cost effective Alternatives also check
out their B12 and caffeine toothpicks
see for yourself why so many people have
switched to zipx 2 picks you can only
get zipx online go to zipxtoothpix.com
and get 10 off with the code Pacman the
link is down below